[Musique]
rencontrant tout près d'ici je lui dis
mademoiselle que fait vous donc dans la
vie et
bien
[Musique]
po on a dansé toute la nuit puis au jour
on est parti chez moi discuter de
l'amour de l'amour et des fruits
se trouva très bien chez moi aussitôt
elle s'installa et le soir en guise de
dîner elle me faisait manger des pommes
des
[Musique]
poires ça ne pouvait pas durer longtemps
car les fruits c'est comme
l'amouruser
modérément t quand je lui dis faut se
quitter aussitôt elle
Séa mon pauvre ami des types comme toi
on en trouve
[Musique]
parliomir
la leçon que j'en ai tiré est facile à
deviner au palmarès ils vaut mieux jouer
plutôt que de
croquer les
[Musique]
fomesir
[Applaudissements]